you've got things going on what we do in
the shadows yeah which by the way I
first of all I love the movie
um taiki with Titi
mother God it has a Taiko ITT right I
saw the movie and I fell in love with it
I couldn't get the song out of my head
you're dead you're dead I swear Ryan
loves the show I love the show I don't
watch many shows and this is one that I
watch I haven't started the fourth
season yeah catch up uh I'm going to
catch up but what what I'm current on it
you're correct oh yeah oh tonight's new
episode yeah
but it's what an exciting
show to be on
and you were you uncertain that they
were going to pick it up because they
waited a while didn't they well I didn't
know if we were gonna well first of all
I didn't know I was gonna get the role
because Guillermo was ran 20 years older
than I am and so I I got the audition by
by accident I went to wine and cheese
night
you had Hawaiian and cheese why and
she's neither my friend Mimi Michaels
was having that's not that's on her
stage and that's her name Mimi Michaels
Mimi Michaels we met in a commercial set
years and years ago became friends and
she just had a newborn and she had
brought the baby to see the family here
on the West Coast her brother uh it was
her her husband the baby her at her
brother's house and she was like just
come by say hi I won't see you for you
know who knows because I'm gonna go back
to the east coast and I haven't been
able to get back there at that point
so is it okay so I went to the wine
cheese night I met this girl who was
there her name was Yvonne her friend uh
from before that I never met before and
we didn't talk about the Hollywood or
business or anything we're just having
like a good old time and the next day I
get a text from an unknown number and I
was like hey you were so [ __ ] funny
last night I was like thanks
who's this enjoy it's Yvonne and I was
like oh Yvonne from last night I got
your number from Mimi's uh I hope that's
okay and I was like yeah that's fine and
I think you should audition for my
fiance's new show and I was like your
fiance's new show yeah it was your
fiance yeah exactly I was like okay I
don't do those kind of films and then
she was like no but you should hurry
because her cat they've cast everyone in
this show except for this role and I was
like okay so I call my agent and tell
her her fiance is Garrett bash at the
time who produces the show and I told my
age I was like I gotta get in for this
show and they're like okay we'll get you
the script and they're like oh wait the
characters are you sure that's the
character I was like yeah it's 20 years
older than you are and I was like oh she
said I'd be fine for it so I'm gonna
believe a stranger you know go with that
and they're like on the whim and I was
like well maybe I shouldn't go in for it
and they're like and I said who's
casting it and it's like Allison Jones I
was like I was like Allison Jones if you
know Allison Jones in Hollywood I was
like she's cast everything that I've
always loved you know bridesmaids the
office Fresh Prince Golden Girl Like You
Name It you know what I mean and I was
just like I go meet her I've never met
her so I was like okay this is my chance
I'll just meet her I'll just make myself
look older so I got this long sleeve
orange shirt and brown sweater vest and
Harry Potter glasses and I don't know
like a yellow rose and the one that I
knew at that time wasn't a poster of my
writing partner's um office and it was
Guillermo del Toro and it was from his
Monster's book and he had his hair
curled to the sides like this and he had
round glasses and I was like I was like
I'll mimic that so I mimicked my look
off of how long did you have to learn
your lines there was like the uh the
complimentary audition as I call it uh
they called that day and the audition
was the next day did you learn all your
lines I learned everything I went home
and like went over it and I was like oh
[ __ ] he is older and I was like okay I
want to go play it at my age I'll play
him at my age now fine that's fine so I
was really looking forward to meet
Allison going to the office and we're
like I'm here to meet Allison Jones like
oh she's not here I was like well no I
have an audition for her no we'll put
you on tape she's in London audition for
Guillermo's
okay so I was like great and then they
put a microphone on me and I've been the
casting associate who's wonderful too
and he was like okay and then I remember
doing it and I was looking up and then
he's a harvey now yeah
and he goes you're done
and I was like oh I think I just
completely went away like I don't
remember what I did for the audition and
I was like oh thank you you were so into
it I was so into it that you forgot what
you had done you didn't know if you'd
done well nothing you've done poorly
nope
so I walk out I'm walking out the door
and he goes Harvey wait and I go I think
he's in a year ago in a Hollywood kid
you know you should go to the next level
he goes to the microphone
we need the microphone and he took the
microphone off of me and I was like oh
shoot I I think I messed it up and then
I went outside and my agent calls her
how'd you do and I was like I don't know
and I was like well we'll check in we'll
see two hours later they called back and
they had shown everyone at FX taika
Jermaine Paul Stephanie like her fiance
uh Garrett had seen it Allison at scene
in London and they all agreed to test me
unanimously they were like it was the
first time they voted to test someone
unanimously at the first for the whole
run and that was gonna be the wild card
because I was too young and I was like
[ __ ] I was like okay it's fine I'll get
to meet them eventually you know I'll do
the the test and whatnot
foreign